foreign
I just wanted to take a little bit of
family time and be honest so
um
Zach Ford who helps with my social media
if you've listened to this show for more
than 11 seconds you know that I was born
in the wrong Century I don't really
understand how all the internets work
and
um so he takes clips from this show and
cuts them up and edits them and then
puts them up on social media platforms
and he posted one and it was me telling
people hey if you tell your kid that you
make me mad or you make me angry or you
make me frustrated
um
you're you're giving your kid that kid a
burden that they are not strong enough
to carry
and I went on to say in that little
media clip
um it's from this show
that I often have to Circle back to my
son I often have to Circle back to my
daughter and say hey I told you earlier
you're really frustrating me you're
really making me mad you're not you
don't have that kind of power I chose to
be frustrated I chose to be mad and I'm
sorry that I put that burden on you the
number of people who wrote me personally
or who
wrote um in the comment section now I
trust you
because you talked about how you screw
this up you're not just here on this
show talking down at us or talking at us
but you're more talking with us and if
you're willing to admit on this show
that this happens in your home then
um we're willing to listen
and that got me thinking
um
I tell you what the last couple of weeks
on the gang who work on this show
um
it's been a mess everybody's going
through a lot and I'm going through a
lot like
um and so I
it occurred to me that there's a that
maybe by the way we I set the show up
right people call in and they ask hey
what should I do next whether it's a
mental health issue or it's a marriage
issue or I don't know what to do with my
kids
and
um I walk alongside people there's this
idea that once you arrive at a certain
amount of knowledge or life experience
everything's just perfect everything
just works itself out
and that's not true
and in fact
um I think it can be harder because I
should have all the answers to stuff and
then I end up saying something stupid or
I should know how to have the right
conversation with my wife and I don't I
just avoid it because I don't want to
have it I'm just tired or whatever and
so
um
I talked with Kelly this morning I just
wanted to I don't know I have a little
the family time and just kind of be
honest for the folks working on the Dr
John deloney show who are here providing
hope and all these answers for everybody
um we've all been going through it and
so folks back there in the booth
um
what's been going on in y'all's life
I'll start
um I'm Kelly and I'm Kelly yes you're
not an alcoholic um not yet no actually
I don't drink that much thankfully
because this past couple weeks
um you know everybody knows because
you've mentioned it on the show I lost
my mom
um last week and I have a special needs
child who
got an infection in the bone in her foot
and she ended up in the hospital so she
was in the hospital when we found out my
mom died so you know all things at once
um I have a son that's failing two
classes currently in high school and I
like you the other day I let loose on
him about it and then the next day had
to come back and say I screwed that up
I'm really sorry
I'm going to help you instead of you
know yelling at you and you know my
husband has medical issues right now
that's causing some big problems in our
marriage and it's just been a lot one of
those yeah yeah it just uh it kind of
feels like when it rains it pours
so it's been a lot lately and then it
pours it floods then when it floods yeah
I go under yeah yeah so well that's what
it feels like lately normally my normal
bent is to just you know we've hung out
for a million times in the past couple
years
um is to start like well you know and I
won't do that I'll just say I'm sorry
that sucks and you're my friend and I'm
sorry
that sucks
who else what else is going on back
there uh yeah I'll go uh been a pretty
uh crappy year uh let's see my wife uh
Katie tore her ACL and uh May
uh got fired uh from her job right
before she had surgery oh man and uh
I got hit by an 18-wheeler pretty
recently totaled my car yes uh and then
uh Katie got kovid last week so we had
to miss the Christmas party and
yesterday uh she lost her job again her
new job and uh so we just been going
through it man just horrible horrible
year and we're in that place where it
doesn't feel like there's hope right now
yeah just to be real about it put the
lights out yeah I mean we just got our
teeth knocked in and uh you know you
just you just picked all your teeth off
the ground and put them in and then they
got kicked out right I have fully full
dentures right now exactly
ah and I'm not gonna lie they don't fit
well all right they're not great man
yeah well as your friend and as the
leader of my band
I'm sorry man thank you
like to see you walk in every day just
keep putting it in and putting it in and
putting it in even though I know like
behind the scenes things are on fire man
sorry appreciate that
yeah hello
uh yeah so it's been quite a year uh
more specifically quite a holiday season
for us
um
and for everybody who doesn't know that
was Ben Hill who runs the board and this
is Sarah who
God help her is the editor the final
editor of the show and she makes sure
this show the disaster that it is in
reality looks different and sounds
different when it finally gets out but
um it has been tough holiday season huh
yeah it's been a big one um a week
before Thanksgiving my grandmother and
my great-grandmother passed away and we
knew it was coming she was 98 years old
but
um she passed and she was just
everything and wonderful wonderful to me
and definitely showed me what
unconditional love was and I didn't know
what that was until it was with her
um and then three days later my
childhood hero took his own life and it
just kind of rocked everything and it
was a battle of how do I
compartmentalize grieving my grandmother
and then graving this hero that needed
help
um and yeah it's just been kind of nuts
just this holiday season and then with
all of our team going through stuff it's
been tough
I'm I've
I'm
sorry
I hate that
um
yeah you're such a gift to so many
millions of people but the work you do
and I'm I'm sorry thank you well you've
been such a blessing to us too because
the reaction the results of those deaths
resulted in me having panic attacks
about dying too soon and being able to
come to you for help in that and be
honest with you you've been such a gift
to me as well so thank you yeah you were
actually Susan from North Dakota the
other day on the show I'm just kidding
you weren't you weren't
um man anybody else having a rip roaring
time back there
how's your I don't know if it's okay to
ask we can edit this out but how's your
daughter for those who don't know Nate
who runs all the YouTube videos stuff
has was diagnosed with cancer how's she
doing
yeah
um on the cancer front it's been uh good
news actually she was given only a 25
chance of it not coming back and uh so
far as she has been in that odds or it
has not come back and she hasn't had to
go through
um chemo or anything like that so we're
just kind of keeping our fingers crossed
she's still at like about 25 now her
odds have improved so now there's only
about a 25 chance of it coming back so
her odds have continuously gotten better
um but uh yeah it's been really good she
has her last Saint Jude's appointment uh
next month so it's been one little
bright spot of good news uh for us
though it's it's been a hard season of
we have four kids and so
um not only the challenges of her cancer
but also
um having four littles
um and we just we don't have much family
support at all and we are very alone and
my wife and I's lives are very different
she's a stay-at-home mom and so the
disparity of what our lives are we can't
relate to each other much these days and
it's really lonely and isolating yeah um
especially for her being at home that's
really hard and
um has put a lot of strain on just us
and our relationship and it's been a
rough season rough year
thank you for sharing that yeah man
anybody else
yeah for me
um I just I feel like my mental health
has just taken a huge hit this winter
just like I deal with seasonal affective
disorder like we talked in the show a
few episodes back like really bad
especially this time of year and so for
me being in that low and then hearing
all these things happening to my friends
you know it's it's hard for me because I
take that on when I know I shouldn't
um and then going home it's like then I
find I sometimes will take it out on my
husband and I don't mean to so he's
actually been coming with me to my like
therapy sessions lately because I'm like
I don't want to have that happen like I
don't want to bring that on him and so
for us we've kind of been not struggling
too much in the sense of that but just
like making sure that this isn't become
like a forever thing where in these
Seasons where I'm going through this
mental health issues I'm not adding him
into the mix gotcha gotcha
well thank you for sharing that thank
you for joining our team
and holding us all up while we're
falling apart we're trying to get these
shows out
um and I get on a
personal note just
um
this past year has been the wildest year
of my professional life
um with a book coming out and
all the metrics
it's just I mean it's like a cliche it
is it couldn't be more of a cliche the
metrics like number one best-selling
book and it sold really well and then
we're
in sold out auditoriums all across the
country doing Live Events and uh
and then all of a sudden you look up and
like Nate just mentioned I have a very
different life than my wife does and she
isn't used to people coming up to us in
the airport or checking to see what
clothes she's wearing out at uh you know
at the airport and judging that with
their preconception of who she was and
uh and then I jumped right into writing
a new book and right into so
um yeah there's just a season of some
hard conversations we have to have and
some grieving about this time of our
life was over and this is going to be
the new part of our life and I wouldn't
change it for the world it's been an
amazing ride and we've been able to help
a whole bunch of people and the the
but man it's been it's wreaked havoc at
home
um and not to mention my my whoop strap
here my HRV this morning is just me
being honest was 14 1-4
my I got a message from the whoop strap
do not exercise today
it told me you have to stop or your
body's about to shut you down and I
don't like to stop I left work early
yesterday I just went home and went to
bed
um and that's not just like because I
don't feel good it's because I've
completely run myself into the ground
and
um I know my kids wear that I know my
wife wears that and I know I spend hour
upon hour preaching to you all not to do
that and here I've turned around I've
done it and so
um here's here's what this wasn't just
for to share in our misery this is just
to let you all know we're people too and
I don't ever want you sitting at home to
think man it must be nice to have my
life so perfect and all together and
everything great
um
because there is no there there's no
place where you can get where somebody
doesn't pass away that you love there's
never going to be a place that you get
when someone you care about doesn't lose
their job or your marriage goes through
a season when you're like I don't know
who you are anymore
um there's never gonna be a moment when
your kids don't do something and you're
like um
what are you doing
um
that is life
and ultimately if I could pass along one
thing that I appreciate about you guys
is everybody's there for each other and
everybody calls each other and says hey
I need to check in you got a minute to
talk
um I am going to be late tomorrow I'm
not coming in tomorrow I got you and it
all comes back to that one idea that you
gotta have people in your life
not if but when things go sideways you
gotta have people and if you're blessed
to work with people like I am I'm
blessed to work with and call my friends
and my community that's awesome and if
you're not that sucks but you still got
to go find those people and um
I know because you send me your notes
and you write me letters and I talk to
you personally
I know there's a lot of people out there
struggling going through hard stuff I
just want you to know
we're right there with you and you're
not alone I also believe with all my
heart I wouldn't do the show that
there's hope around every corner
we just gotta lock arms with the people
in our lives and we got to walk forward
sometimes in the dark
sometimes and only they can see
and make sure we're walking towards that
hope
so I love you guys
love you all and for those y'all who are
listening I love you guys too we're all
all in this together
have the hard conversation you need to
have start there